are there certain defensive phrases that
you see as red flags when a writer gets
notes back and you kind of can already
tell they're gonna go there and how to
coach them so that they don't ruin their
relationship with whatever Studios
hiring them because of this
defensiveness because of this will no no
this isn't gonna work and it's just
there's no yeah I would say like I'll
never forget when I was a studio
executives there was a certain
circumstance where this happened where
we had the network the studio and the
showrunners and the writer on the phone
and the writer was so defensive to the
network notes and it was my job to go to
the writer and say you need to really
hear the note understand the note and
then your pet best response that isn't
going to put somebody on the defense or
isolate someone is I'll take a look at
it okay that helps to first of all it
helps it's positive on the writer it's
saying that they're open it's not saying
they agree with the note but it's saying
they're open so take a look at it and
that's all people want to know what I
think the biggest thing writers have to
think about when it comes to receiving
notes on their script is even if they
don't agree with the note at face value
they have to understand there might be a
note under the note and the note they
need to make to themselves is something
isn't working and I have to figure out
how to make it work because if this
person who knows story is not getting it
then there's something going on in my
process
that isn't working and just be open to
that I mean the gift with writing what I
say to writers is you have to recognize
first of all the what is the blank page
is the only thing that is between them
and a writing career and how they fill
that page is what makes the difference
so they can rewrite anything like that's
why I say to writers I cannot tell you
it was my job
how many showrunners I had to talk off
the ledge after they heard notes and
after they heard notes from the studio
or the owner of the company or the I had
to be the peacemaker and I had to really
help them to see alright at first I
think the writers mind may go oh my god
there's a total page one rewrite very
often it's not all it is is really
thinking about the note understanding
the note and then if they're open to it
what they what I've seen the best writer
for me knows how to make the note and go
beyond the note so sorry and that takes
openness you know that takes advanced
ability to really know all right well
I'm gonna make that note there and
therefore that's going to affect a later
moment so I'm going to change that later
moment so that it links with what I just
changed and they know how to do that
interesting so it's not ok here you go
I changed this part there you have it
right now what's wrong right interesting
okay what are some of the common defense
phrases like you know these are just
suits what do they know I mean that's
being very crude but but I mean what
what are some of the things that really
they use as their wall when they receive
these notes
I think probably the biggest wall note
is saying you're wrong I don't agree I
think that is that shows lack of
openness and accessibility and desire to
make the story better so I I think you
know when writers will or they'll say I
don't get it and then the executive or
or the story consultant will go through
it again
and and I think like this is where I
think it comes to the person giving the
note there's also tremendous
responsibility I am definitely a
believer that if you're gonna give a
note give an example show them what you
mean so that they understand the note so
I mean there are many consultants who
will say I don't think that's my job I'm
not the writer they're the writer I am a
believer I come from the studio
executive perspective where clarity is
key in the outcome of the story so if
you're going to give a note and give an
example of why it's not working or what
you mean by it then you're going to have
a stronger chance of getting the outcome
that you want
you